I really didn't like football growing up
I was really like a basketball player I
think that's kind of why I like playing
basketball game for real first we going
to start with the acceleration think we
going to go to blocking all right we go
to get this three ball I started playing
2K in like 2019 after that I just like I
haven't stopped playing the game I ain't
got nothing to do I probably sit there
all day and
play I like the new city mainly like the
stores cuz they give you more options
like a lot a lot of clothes a lot of
different stuff you can get all right
just got some drip some swags about to
head
to jump man put some kicks
on hey I used to really suck and then I
I got really good by playing with you
know other people and now like everybody
be wantan around with me all the time
yeah it is kind of cool like meet new
people on the game and just be able to
play the game with them
oh no defense no
nothing